what up space fam goes in here from
anime upper back at it again to discuss
the latest and craziest developments in
the one piece story and this is a big
one we get to see the conclusion of zoro
vs king we get to see king unmasked and
much more so make sure to stay tuned for
this one if you do enjoy these one-piece
chapter reviews i want to keep them
coming you know what to do channel the
piraking within and smash that like
button with no mercy remember smashing
that like button is pirate king energy
and passing is
energy so choose wisely if you haven't
make this the video subscribe and this
is crucial hit that notification bell to
turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one piece videos and updates
and while you wait for the next exciting
chapter to drop feel free to check out
my huge and growing one piece playlist
that includes videos about the yonko
warlord supernova and much more link to
that is in the description and now
without further ado let's jump into it
spoilers and all this chapter is called
zorro vs king which is similar in its
construction to the last chapter title
which was sanji vs queen in sanji vs
queen we saw sanji win so the
implication is that here it's zoro's
turn to do the same very hype right from
the get-go the chapter starts with the
aftermath of the sanji vs queen fight
queen is beat up and sent flying and it
looks like he's literally blasting off
like team rocket i say that all the time
but here like it's actually like that
from the looks of it he fell off the
entire floating island he'll either land
in the water or potentially on land if
they're above land at this point either
way it doesn't look like he's going to
be an issue anymore epic victory from
sanji it's difficult for it to sink in
that our sanji just crushed a dude with
a bounty of 1.32 billion berries he just
beat the second strongest fighter of
kaido's crew and kaido has the highest
bounty of all living yonko the straw
hats are fast approaching the apex of
the pirate world unless blackbeard did
something crazy off-screen luffy's
bounty should skyrocket over blackbeard
soon it almost feels like blackbeard has
to beat shanks or do something else
that's absolutely mind-blowing to make
the luffy vs blackbeard fight make more
sense because just fighting a lower
bound to yonko after beating the highest
bounty yonko just doesn't sound that
exciting but back to sanji who is still
a gentleman despite his monstrous
strength and we are glad to see it while
the woman who thought he was the violent
one is frightened of what he'll do he
ends up delivering the mouse truji that
she was looking for she thanks him and
it's funny to think sanji not only beat
queen but made sure to protect the mouse
at the same time sanji recalls his own
mouse friend who he used to feed as a
kid these two seem like a pretty good
match now that sanji has been cleared
since she does seem like a kind person
at heart and they both share an interest
in pet mice which is pretty unique i
feel like sanji continues to talk to her
to see if she's okay but then if i'm
interpreting this right he collapses
from exhaustion and she yells for
someone to get a first aid kit it seems
like queen did push sanji to the point
of extreme exhaustion which makes sense
it would be pretty insane if sanji just
carried on like nothing happened after
beating someone so strong and it also
explains why he probably won't be
available to participate in other wano
fights we then jump to the main event of
the chapter zorro vs king if sanji was
in bad shape after his battle we can
only imagine how zoro will feel
afterwards since all of his wounds and
pain will be compounded when his
medicine wears off but for now he's
going strong he looks awesome with his
flaming swords his attack hurts king and
zorro in this way confirms that king is
faster when the flames on his back go
out but his defenses get weaker it
finally makes sense when zorro was
thinking that knowledge of the lunarians
would help him in this fight because
they clearly have weaknesses that can be
exploited if you know about them at this
point the craziness happens king takes
off his mask that's been destroyed even
more by zoro's last attack and it may
come as a surprise that oda made him a
very handsome dude with tanned skin and
long white hair it looks like he could
be one of those buff dudes on the cover
of those cheap romance novels sometimes
you feel like masks could be hiding a
disfigured face but definitely not in
this case and it kind of makes sense
that he's good looking since the
lunarians were known as a tribe of gods
and even had wings like angels to match
the angelic aesthetic everyone is
shocked when they see the rumors were
true and they begin to say the world
government is offering 100 million
berries for any info on dot dot dot but
king cuts them off with an imperial
dragon attack and burns them zorro tells
him not to treat his men like that but
king clearly felt like he couldn't trust
them since there is so much incentive to
rat out lunarians to the government zoro
again asks about king's race and i think
we all want to know more about the
lunarians but unfortunately king says
why should i bother you'll be dead soon
i feel like this is oda poking fun at
how usually when a character thinks
they're about to kill someone they
randomly start telling them their life
story and oda is like nope why bother
telling it if the person will be dead
soon anyway it's a funny twist but i do
nonetheless desperately want to know
more information about the lunarians we
get an interesting moment after some
blows have been exchanged where zorro
says i don't have much time if we keep
dragging things out this sword will kill
me clearly he's referring to enma the
key to his new power up here and
interestingly enough instead of putting
on a poker face and acting like he's
fine king admits that he too feels close
to his limit thus they both established
this will be over soon they're giving it
their all to end it quick zorro thinks
to himself that king's race being
special doesn't change anything for him
which is funny because he did previously
say he needs to know its secret to win
but he could also mean unlike all the
people have freaked out because of the
government award for lunarian
information zoro doesn't care he'll
simply fight him as another respectable
warrior in battle zoro says they're in
the same boat since they are close to
their limits but he says king has had
his time at the top and it's time to
make room for us probably meaning the
straw hats and yeah you could say that
kaido as the highest bounty yonko was on
top of the power world in a sense but
still he was no pirate king the concept
parallels between zoro and king are also
interesting aside from both of them
being right hand men who use swords they
are both associated with kings and
dragons as zoro says he's using king of
the underworld 3 sword style while king
says that the straw hats shouldn't get
ahead of themselves because kaido will
be the next pirate king we get a much
appreciated king and kaido flashback
it's a pretty epic encounter i must say
kaido is breaking out of the experiments
laboratory held by the government he
tells king that they'll never let a
lunarian go and asks king if he wants to
come along and join kaido's pirate crew
that he's gonna form clearly king was a
day 1 crewmate for kaido king first asks
if kaido will be able to change the
world and kaido says and this is so epic
i am the only one who can this young
title's look and eyes are so full of
life and belief here this is before he
became the more jaded always drinking
version of himself that he is today he
definitely had more luffy vibes here
it's hilarious to see how they are
casually walking away as people are
screaming from behind that the test
subjects have escaped king reveals his
real name is arbor and kaido tells him
he's worthy of a stronger name and dubs
him king he says if he stands by him
kaido will never sell him out which is a
very nice moment between these two
characters even antagonists can have
these heartwarming moments and you can
tell why king is so loyal to kaido here
not only did kaido save him he's one of
the few people who wouldn't give him to
the government and sell him out he also
believed in him enough to give him a
powerful name and he still identifies
with this name today love seeing these
fleshed out dynamics from opposing crews
i must say and i appreciate these
moments because it shows kaido can be a
decent guy in certain contexts and he's
not just pure evil which usually makes
for boring villains in my view they
continue to fight and while king's fire
is burning zoro is not doing damage they
clash and king tries to use his weird
sword to take zorro's swords like last
time but it doesn't work zoro says king
is not taking these name swords of his a
pretty hyped statement i love the
respect and love he has for his swords
then zoro notices kings moving fast aka
he can cut him down because his flames
are deactivated in a truly impressive
moment zorro outspeeds king's fast form
and cuts him with bird dance zoro then
notices that king is blocking his
attacks meaning that king is no longer
confident in his ability to take zorro's
attacks without damage zorro is clearly
on the offensive here the momentum is
working in his favor now king tries to
say a being like zorro probably implying
a mere human can't win against him but
zorro is not having it saying you can
shove that excuse right back where it
came from i love zorro no excuses king
still tries to act patronizing saying
and i quote i'll remember you as a
swordsman that held some skill and quote
the implication is that it's been fun
you were alright better than i thought
but i'm about to end it zorro in
response as if king survives zoro will
beat the memory of himself into his
skull king launches what looks like a
flashy final attack it's called imperial
guardian flaming dragon and i love the
fact that it unleashes the actual fire
or magma azor implied dragon at zorro we
wanted to see dragon slayer zorro and in
a sense we get that here zorro uses the
move underworld king's three bladed
dragons using the idea of kinks and
dragons for himself too and cuts through
king's flaming dragon and then him
taking off a wing in the process we're
told by the narrator with one swing even
dragons are torn asunder and that is the
end of this epic epic chapter and props
to how much that narration hypes up
zorro we know how strong and mythical
the idea of dragons are and yet it said
with one swing zorro takes him out
really loved the fact that zoro got his
chance to overcome a dragon in a sense
at least that was an epic chapter and it
really seems like the end of this fight
which means wano is wrapping up pretty
quickly at this point we just need to
deal with kaido and big mom in one way
or another zorro did the unbelievable he
if i'm not mistaken beat the yonko
commander with the highest known bounty
of any yonko commander he beat the right
hand man to the strongest creature in
the world if you want to use the
lunarian mythology and symbolism you
could say zorro took down a god
absolutely insane stuff one piece is
almost unrecognizable at this point
because of how far the straw hats have
come in terms of power but yeah let me
know your thoughts on this chapter and
what you're looking forward to most in
the next one obviously i think we all
gotta agree that zoro was mvp this
chapter there's no doubt about that in
my mind if you did enjoy this review and
want to keep them coming you know what
to do channel the pirate king within and
smash that like button with no mercy
remember smashing that like button is
pirate king energy and passing is orochi
energy so choose wisely if you haven't
make this the video subscribe and this
is crucial hit that notification about
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one-piece videos and updates
and while you wait for the next exciting
chapter to drop feel free to check out
my huge one piece playlist that includes
videos on all the yonko warlords
supernova and much more link to that is
in the description and i especially want
to thank the patron squad over on
patreon here on youtube who helped make
videos like this one possible first and
foremost i want to thank the patrons of
legend the ones acknowledged by lord
tuigo himself alpha sigma and kyle
salisbury and are the one-tier patrons
the ones who stand atop all clans
ingrata al jatal but they have fun the
red-haired fox hinokami and water the
toasted chi cory mcgowan the spike
lonely the car dylan isadore spidey
light tanel tungsten tarkis big buddhist
jeremy cummings and shaye whitley and
our pro hero to your patrons the one and
only gilgamesh steelers angel crews very
gucci alicia actor bonnie parks ryan
garcia fat boy games kaido might be a
duck jessica rabbit jeremy phillips
alivenia temple king matthew and
demetrius water thank you all so much if
you do enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon.com
and me uproar and becoming a patron
today for as little as one dollar if you
do so you'll get your name featured in
future videos alongside these amazing
epic people right here and you'll get
access to our private patron only
discord where we talk about anime life
and of course thank meme so check out
patreon.com anime upload link in the
description if you're interested you can
also join the youtube channel by
clicking that blue join button next to
subscribe button that you hopefully
already destroyed so yeah you can
support more content that way if you
prefer and whichever way you support us
you can get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
my
you